foreign
[Music]
application the cloud accessible from
anywhere and anytime is one of the
greatest convenience isn't it but you
need to keep in mind to protect your
applications for potential threats one
of the first steps of shielding
applications is firewall rules the
challenge is configuring firewall rules
properly so you can decrease risk while
you still keeping the right connectivity
between your resources in this episode
you will learn how to troubleshoot
firewall rules Google cloud has tools
that you can use to verify which flows
was denied that or permitted let's start
if you are not familiar with what viral
rules do and what they are for I would
recommend you to watch the protect your
Google Cloud instances With viral rules
YouTube video the link is shown on this
slide
today I'll show you how to troubleshoot
and resolve a connectivity issue cause
the two misconfigured viral rules
for this demo I will use this network
topology which consists of two compute
engine's name server VM and client VM
hosting two different vpcs connected via
VPC peering hyper fertility is installed
to test the communication between client
and server or any TCP UDP ports
let's SSH to the server VM and Clyde VM
Saturday I performed the server to
listen on Port 5000 the client sends
packets to the server on Port 5000.
we are not getting any packets on the
server
Let's test the reachability run the Ping
command it's working this indicates
there is communication between these two
VMS but packets are not arriving on the
server let's check the firewall rules
go to the firewall page in the Google
Cloud console in the search bar type VPC
Network and select it in the search
results
on the far left column select the
firewall
this tape contains all of the final
rules for this project
there is a viral rule that allows
everything
hmm why is still not working
to investigate his father we must look
into the final rules logs
great the final rules log is enabled for
this rule this is excellent tool to
troubleshoot
viral rules logs allowed you to update
your final rules it is also useful if
you need to determine how many
connections are affected by a given fire
rule
it locks traffic to and from computer
engines and Google kubernetes engines
you enable the log for viral rule this
gives you flexibility to only lock the
connections you want to investigate
later
to learn how to enable disable firewall
rules logs check out this documentation
alright now let's check the viral rules
logs
click view in logs Explorer here is the
query to view blogs for all of the final
rules
oh there are a few denies actions in
this log list
let's get the details of this one
destination IP 10112 destination Port
5000 Source IP
10122 and it says denied
this is our flow
oh here's the room deny the destination
10 1 0 0 16 for TCP ports range from one
thousand to six thousand
as verified earlier there is a rule to
allow everything
ah must be priority the priority for the
final rule that the nice TCP ports is
one thousand
and the one that allows everything is
ten thousand there you go this is the
issue keep in mind the lower value means
higher priority of the file rule
since the priority for the night rule
has a lower value it is blocking the
flow
to fix this issue we can either delete
this viral rule or change the priority
I will lower the priority for the deny
rule by increasing the value to 50 000.
let's retest
Yahoo is working now
fire logs are essential tool for
troubleshooting final rules to unblock
yourself and your applications to numb
is the second part of this
troubleshooting video stay tuned if you
want to learn more check out the
documentation linked below
thank you for watching
[Music]